i hope you can talk to me
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com
now after black oh mugskibar made his
point to the splc loud and clear youtube
decided to enlist the help of some
unexpected allies
see they needed private companies to do
their bidding free from the constraints
of a non-profit organization
so what better than one of the largest
entertainment corporations in the world
if blacco sent a message youtube decided
that it was time to send one back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
us
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you're supposed to be dead
he killed you
so i've been told
how did you the preservation of mug club
in my absence is much appreciated
[Music]
all your tremendous work has not gone
unnoticed
even brandon
you're dead i had to take over i had to
take charge
tell me blacco
do you feel in charge
i missed it
scent of fear
of intimidation
it is palpable
but it is misplaced
i've returned
not as an adversary
but an ally
a liberator
[Music]
i've heard of your conflicts with the
splc
of the false dmca's from the rodents
of your run-ins
with the glorified latinx setbacks
i have it under control
no
blocko
that is merely a delusion
so i appreciate your view
it warms my cockles
and a far more sinister forces of foot
that even you realize
but hear this promise
if you follow me
i will lead you
and restore my crumb to its former glory
and together we will fight
we will win
and we will restore my club
to empower the likes of which youtube
has never seen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
hmm
yes that's a nice sip on a cold day cold
front
coming here through uh through uh texas
and uh basically uh everywhere so we
actually feel a kinship with a guest
we're going to have on the show today
big big day bj dick dirt that's his
actual name
bj dictor is uh one of the members of
the uh the trucker convoy for freedom
over there in in canada we have him live
on the ground the reason we're late
today is because he actually drove off
in a ditch because their roads were a
little sleety and naily um
so looking forward to having him out we
have a lot of uh of other stories to get
to but yeah showing some support with
our canadian brethren here we're all
wearing our toques dave control room
even uh even gerald i hate every one of
you right now well you know what we ran
out of here we don't necessarily have a
jim henson budget here no listen you
handed this to me first and there was a
full bend behind you yeah on youtube
vagina
yeah you did this to me ah that's what
it is it's a nice it's a nice snook took
dick for help damn near killed her so oh
geez come on let's not make fun of the
man's name oh i gotta lift my nose i'm
not it's
at the end it's not his fault i'll do it
this way no way it's so comfy uh before
and before we move on with everything
else by the way if you want to continue
my clubhouse uh let us know down below
and yes uh it's a live show monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern i know
today we're late but youtube
notifications subscriptions don't always
work so if you miss us here on youtube
go to rumble go to mug club where today
we have a full additional hour
including some neil young songs which
could never be played on
youtube and uh yeah mug club consider
joining up that's uh
we may because youtube doesn't pay us
nothing so uh my question is how much do
you know about the canadian convoy going
on that is the question of the day
a lot of americans don't necessarily
know how important it is how much it
affects you here and of course now when
we see facebook removing similar groups
in the united states just took a 20
something percent to nosedive their
stuff
so you take the wins where you can get
them whoopi's gone
facebook taking a nosedive and let's
take another win here uh look i don't
care who's running the country as it
relates to this whether it's former vice
president uh joe biden or president
harris
[Music]
president donald trump
the
leader of isis abu ibrahim al-hashimi i
hope i'm getting that right oh how
couldn't you be killed in syria yeah
that's what people will be upset about
like well you didn't get his name right
yeah okay you know what fine i'll check
my white privilege when he stops begging
six-year-old girls how about that 83
octaves in your name yes
i don't have the back of the throat spit
enough because we're all a little bit
sick
so uh the pentagon stated that if we're
trusting what the pentagon says that the
man actually
triggered a bomb which killed himself
and unfortunately 13 civilians including
four women and six children no u.s
casualties look look uh well first off
hey you know what this guy's dead so
take that win good on you america yeah
[Music]
okay but i feel like another one bites
the dust would have been appropriate as
well sand
another one bites ascend
and you would with that hat you just
play the lawrence of arabia theme
another one bites the pillow now here
come on
13 civilians killed four women six
children look this is terrible obviously
a coward
and i think it's also a testament to
when people say the united states is
just as evil as these other countries
look the united states obviously i don't
think we should police the world i'm
more of a non-interventionist i don't
believe in most of these foreign wars
you guys know that pretty well but when
was the last time you heard
or you've heard of a general
do you remember patton blowing himself
up and taking out six kids yeah
macarthur it's not something we do let's
not act as if there's a moral
equivalency okay this is a man who cares
so little about the people
who for whom he's fighting
that he killed them he killed him in a
coward's way out yeah exactly uh
mohammadi lee
yes
that's not true i prefer muhammad ali no
what are you about to call me an [ __ ]
yes yes i was points
this guy if he's like all right i'm
about to die
you know here's here's your options go
out and fight which i don't want him to
go out and kill american troops so don't
get me wrong of course i'm glad that he
didn't take anybody of our side with him
that's the win
but you just killed six women and
children four children on top of that i
mean
go outside and blow yourself up [ __ ]
oh sorry it's not about killing women
and children
it's about ethnicity oh it is okay thank
you hopefully
you're sounding a little roomy
and your echo it could just be because
my hat is ruining the seal on my head i
think it is so yeah look that's a good
thing and i think we want to be
consistent look
like when rush limbaugh got into all
this trouble uh
god
rest his soul he said you know i want
obama to fail people said you wanted no
he didn't want america to fail he wanted
barack obama to fail in implementing his
policies i don't want america to fail if
america is going to fight isis i want us
to fight them and win i just don't think
that americans have the stomach for war
anymore if you're going to go to war you
only go into war to win to destroy
people break stuff and reap the spoils
this is the problem
here good thing he's dead don't
necessarily know what we're doing at
this point yeah is is is anyone else
sort of is is that is that fair and the
timing to me seems just a little weird
i'm not saying that this had anything to
do with it but biden is looking for
every possible win he can get right now
and so i'm just wondering like okay why
now and it totally could have been legit
like i thought you legit totally fine i
thought you were implying that zucker or
stellar at cnn called like this was
supposed to be on a friday we need to
bury it blow yourself up he's defecting
i had sex with somebody and i'm
resigning now because of you
he's blowing himself up just with little
debbies yes yeah
it's a different blow up
like that hostess twinkie commercial
where the shark sees the person in the
inner two yeah stelter
i'm more of a lunchables man i can fit
it in my murse all the fun you can pack
into a murse now i didn't realize this
was fruit filled
uh also i should i shouldn't i should
introduce you gerald a is here there you
go how are you doing
well because of this
how are you i'm doing all right i've
been responsible for fine it was the
easiest driving to work ever today
people in texas can't drive in the ice i
made it 10 minutes door to door because
there was no one well it was because no
one would actually grip on the roads yes
i ran the red lights because there was
no one i was like
that's the fun part yeah it's
uncomfortable allegedly did you yeah
there was one light where it's like
trade thing yes well of course that's a
different reason but mine is there
there's a light on the way here where
it's two parking lots you know what i'm
talking about there's a bank there's a
mcdonald's it's a parking lot and it's a
light as though it's a major
intersection what the hell am i having
for this light these restaurants aren't
even open right now you should just keep
going i just kept going let's hold on
electronically kept going you don't want
to admit to running i allegedly kept
going well you couldn't stop and hit the
brakes because you would have slid yes
that's what i do is i hit the brakes
where i'm like oh no
oh and then i just drift right through
the red shouldn't have been crossing
with the carriage lady and i tried so
hard to stop and i didn't and uh he's
here with me now you know me let me be
in denver this week but also i'll be
touring with him the tickets are now on
sale for royal oak michigan go to
lotterathcrowder.com
tour i will be doing stand up
with dave landau we have march 26th uh
in indiana yeah then we have uh
somewhere in royal oak michigan was it
april april 16th at the royal oak music
theater it's a great venue it's gonna be
a lot of fun so when the tickets are
selling out really fast in evansville
evansville we're gonna have to add
another show so jump on it if you guys
want to do it okay uh let me move on
here before we uh we have to get to our
guest today so we have to make sure that
we uh you know we stay on time which is
not our strong suit whoops
my strongest is birthday
now uh
we've had our qualms obviously with
russia putin right none of us russia
putin found just like yesterday we had
to clarify hitler mao both bad both bad
yeah real bad
but the russian women
particularly the ones who looked like
they were pulled from into the woods
they are more based
than you would expect here we there's a
man on the street and it's not like
jordan clepper it's not like jaywalking
you know because you could die
because russia uh and uh this is uh from
some grandmas i guess on uh the russian
reddit i guess is where it was found
they definitely have their uh their
issues with uh you could say the new
world government internationalism here
you go just watch
it
[Music]
so
i love how in the states you ask them a
basic question right and a lot of people
can't answer of course it's selectively
edited that's why we try not to we don't
do that here but uh over there you ask
them one question and they give you a
brilliant answer on international
politics this is why they do it for
those listening on audio this is where
the us needs to start thinking with
their brains and not have 40 genders
this is your problem you are not
following science and i i think that you
will no longer be great superpower
because you are making mistake and the
person is just interviewing like uh what
do you think about the kardashians
big asses not for me i like how she
quickly threatened nuclear war yes just
from a man on the street question she's
like yeah i think we'll put nukes right
next to your country see how you like
that i like how every woman interviewed
was beautiful yes
[Laughter]
imagine that shows up on your mail order
bride like amazon prime uh is there a
return policy yes there uh can i just
put a label on this and leave it on the
porch this isn't prime this isn't even
chuck roast
oh
ouch are you made of meth
they don't have meth face i know but
they still have the face they can't get
to make their head because they drink
the antifreeze they have vodka face why
would you use this to make meth when you
can just drink into that sink cleaner i
know it's good oh boy you tie belt to
hand because it's a shake from you know
withdrawal yes and then you bring belt
around neck yes exactly it is like polly
yeah for old lady russian drink instead
is the hand makes you feel good or
sometimes i have my grandson put my hip
on see-saw so i drink from that like
bird on desk yes
one in eight grandsons survive yes
that's why we have 19 also we cannot
afford contraception or bread or as your
bernie says that's a good thing right
you need to stop with stupidity
you wait in line for disney
rollercoaster i wait for s still off and
lois jeans yes very low ah mama jeans
by the way before him hey speaking of
russians you know obviously they're uh
they're they're they share a kinship
with guess who else
african americans it's black history
month here at lodo's grinder uh oh
some uh facts regarding uh uh because we
celebrate it here we honor black history
honor i wish it was a longer month uh on
april 15th 1947 jackie robinson broke
the decades-old color barrier became the
first ever major uh league baseball
player who was black not in the negro
league as uh joe biden said former vice
president biden said from the farm
league yeah and then you have uh you
have uh stat on the nfl here i do jim
brown who i like a lot led the nfl in
rushing yards for eight out of his nine
seasons by the time he retired jim had
shattered almost every major rushing
record there was he is still considered
to be one of the greatest football
players to ever grace the field and wife
beaters also uh if a white man can
finish a whole bucket of nashville hot
chicken
without dying or choking uh he uh
legally gets to coach an nba team that's
true yeah it's an automatic thing it's i
don't even think it's state it's a
federal thing this has been black
history month
okay you just got a free meal and stuff
like that but they really upped their
game yeah speaking of kind of black
history month i was watching cnn this
morning so you don't have to all
reference is available at
lottoworldcredit.com and don lemon
don lemon
you guys thought he was gone you think
he's never gone that's the whole point
he was on scene and promoting his new
show on cnn plus which is their
streaming service right
watch out paramount
cnn plus q yes cnn ip
plus eggplant emoji oh
man skelter get in here oh boy it's
getting salacious bring your murse hey
celtra it's done come in here and make
lemonade yes can you bring your
dunkaroos i always have dunkaroos i'm
made of mostly dunkaroos
i hate it
don lemon was promoting don lemon plus
on scene and i was watching the ad and
he really thought that this was
a selling point it's just so funny that
they're promoting cnn plus on cnn here's
don lemon's new ad for those of you who
are interested i'm don lemon and i'm don
lemon plus we may look alike but we're
different yeah on cnn plus i have even
less of a filter really are you sure
that's good for us
no no no don't try mustache no no
we'll see
i can't wait that thing is going to go
down in flames so
so quickly i mean how many sex offenders
can you fit into a green room they have
trouble getting people to watch their
channel for free
and that's when everyone's tuned in at
the airport it's someone who's stuck at
bojangles in charlotte like ah actually
yeah it's like we didn't flames we're
gonna go down
oh my gosh that's i love i love the idea
of cnn plus this is fantastic well while
in russia they deal with real problems
and the ukraine they deal with real
problems yeah i don't want to minimize
the problems but i'm about to minimize
some problems
uh a mother has opened up this is a
story now about her now this is going to
sound really sinister okay
and you'll think i'm making light of it
until you remember now that it's not
real
a mother opened up about her
traumatizing gang rape wait in
facebook's metaverse ah yes yes so uh
avatar huh yeah this stephen um
look i i appreciate that you want to
make jokes about these things but
this is something that's a really
sensitive subject matter near and dear
to my heart and i'd like to take this
one okay
i i'm sorry i didn't know yet about my
hands i if you think that
[Music]
nina jane patel said yeah
within 60 seconds of joining
i was verbally
and sexually harassed oh
three to four male avatars
with male voices
but virtually gang raped my avatar and
took photos well that wasn't even
consensual no
as i tried to get away
they yelled
don't pretend you didn't love it
and
go rub
yourself off to the photo okay let him
get through it he's this is good for him
i'm just glad we're here
harassment in the metaverse is a serious
issue
and the industry needs to come on
together
you shouldn't come on anything come
together on
to put in place the correct security
controls and safety measures well you
know what we talk about common ground on
the show i think we can all get behind
that we can yes yeah no avatar left
behind no
do i say s k golden corral no no no no
no is that a different thing i don't
know what you tried to get away so when
i tried to run away by pressing up on
the d-pad
i'm sorry david by the way halo those
listening on audio because that was
really for the audio listeners and those
who are not uh you can of course
subscribe to the podcast you know i just
call android and spotify which will be
labeled misinformation even though that
is a real story dave just read it word
for word yeah dave no i just think it's
very serious to rape an avatar yeah i
know dave can you can you tell us was it
three or four i mean he said three to
four um i'm not a counter yeah it was a
he's not a he's not a cpa the point is
it was traumatic couldn't zoom out and
tell us how much look i don't i have to
audit my rapists penises yeah i'm not
like hey get me a count do you know that
92 percent can't write it off of
metaverse rapes uh go unclaimed they go
unprosecuted they don't even get them
they don't even get the digital ratings
it's embarrassing no it's very
embarrassing
it's it's embarrassing you show up to
the digital you don't show up to the
digital downtown the police office they
have their their pixelated swab and they
rape you dave what what was your avatar
wearing
uh
i'm just trying to help
i'm not saying victim blame of avatars
i'm just saying yeah oh no i think i
think you are my avatar was wearing a
pink [ __ ] hat and glasses yep oh
that wasn't really what did it it was
more so the uh the chaps
well well yeah which usually go with the
chaps or the french-made outfit i don't
have to buy it with uh with nfts too
that's true you do also try not go going
to the gang rape avatar room
well you should avoid that chat that's a
good that's a bad place to be i thought
it was an ironic title yeah okay
you never know you never know that's the
thing it's not
you never know gerald
you're right it's an epidemic it is i
liked it i liked it a lot please just
tell me that no police resources were
wasted on this
only avatar police who actually joined
in can you digitally kill yourself can
you do that
i've tried oh well
you can but you come back stupid gosh
you respawn that's a cheat
okay here's another thing going on uh
united states
a united states skier while we're
talking about the winter olympics uh you
know the kickoff in beijing next week
which i don't understand what we're
taking part i feel like we shouldn't
have anything to do with communist
countries period but that's me mr
traditional uh america gonna be in this
america's best freestyle skier eileen gu
gu
gu
go
also is it go stelter's that's what i'm
made of
oh she wants to love you should i have
it for breakfast she won't be downing
the stars and stripes but uh
this is an american the sickle and
hammer here you go
born in san francisco to an american
father and a chinese mother eileen
announced in 2019 that she would ski for
china at the beijing games eileen seems
to be aware of the political sensitivity
around china
on chinese social media plans
her posts focus on her
self-identification as a chinese athlete
and role model for her 1 million
followers this while the us government
announced the diplomatic boycott of the
beijing olympics over concerns about
china's poor human rights record
but if china needs a national hero
eileen seems ready for the job not
american so to be able to introduce just
one young girl to skiing and change her
life the way that mine was changed is
something that's inexorable and so worth
doing and because there's so many taller
than all of them
oh there's so much more opportunity in
china
somewhere behind her there are throngs
of uyghurs going no no no no no no no
just death
just a kill forever not opportunity you
mispronounce death
or torture
there's no way she's more than quarter
asian i i doubt it she's blonde and by
the way i'm i'm i'm sure she picked
china just for the uh
inspiring young athletes that's true
yeah i couldn't have anything to do she
was good enough by the way this thing
could win three gold medals has nothing
to do with finances i'm sure no no no
not at all it can't be a money play so
explain to people who who don't know you
know right so this whole story so so goo
she actually announced to the world
she'd be skiing for china in 2000 and is
it goo or go i don't even know at this
point
you i don't know okay right
she would she decided to uh ski for
china in uh 2019 so she was preparing
for the 2020 yes so here's a quote i've
decided to compete for china in the
upcoming 2022.
read it like goo i have decided to
compete for
china this was incredibly tough decision
for me to make sorry i'm competing for
china and now oh oh oh
oh
she has to be chinese when she's there
that's true so she's like their
equivalent of kamala harris yes i was
listening to yo-yo back in 1968.
well look so uh there there's obviously
a lot of uh a lot of people that are
pissed off about this we'll get to some
of the reasons why but this is possibly
one of them since she announced that
she's a traitor well that too but here's
the thing the question is why like why
would she do that if she could ski in
the united states and for the us and
still win gold medals right she's inc
deals with uh victoria's secret tiffany
iwc and uh of course beats by dre very
big in china uh this makes sense
victoria's secret yeah well no it's a
horny not a lot of secrets but you know
something what's the secret on all a
cups well
not a lot of women in china to market to
i thought with the one child policy but
we'll get to that well they also sell
they also sell foot bindings that say
juicy so i don't know
look it does make a little bit of sense
because china is obviously one of the
biggest economies in the world and
they're on track to be the top place for
luxury goods by 2025 so i guess that
makes sense but she has 23 endorsement
deals from chinese companies including
just a few bank of china china mobile
and
mgnu i have no idea how to pronounce
that but here's the interesting part
each one of those deals is worth roughly
about two and a half million dollars so
far
i don't know
my brain are thinking yen
crying out loud it's just everyone is
looking to be marginalized for some
group like i think it's really important
that the chinese are how about how about
you inspire the chinese athletes there
to defect and get their ass out of china
where they're oppressed hey how many
girls are there in china who look up to
you you know the ones who made it
through the bathtub holocaust right
exactly or we're not left on a mountain
somewhere right die slowly of starvation
right so it's uncertain really how she
can do that right now no you're not what
it's really uncertain how she can do
this legally and be able to ski for
china because they don't allow dual
citizenship for any of their athletes
right so it's not like canada and
america where you have dual citizenship
and you're like oh i didn't make it you
have to renounce yourself exactly in
there right so she has to renounce it
and she was only 15 when she apparently
did that well here's the problem with
that the rub is in the united states for
you to be able to renounce it you have
to be at least 16 years of age so
there's a lot of questions to whether
she can actually legally have done this
if she was announcing it at the time and
there's some kind of foul play with
china we really don't know see i think
that if you commit you know if you're a
trader or if you uh commit treason i
think we just have one age like what i
can i can commit treason but i can't
drink a beer with my buddies it should
be
it should be 18.
and rental insurance yes well that too
25 the golden yeah well for for chinese
drivers it's 45. are they good skiers
though who chinese yeah i don't know
that they have a strong team i feel like
they're not i feel like it's joining the
lions to win a super bowl well they're
just knocking the tibetans off the
himalayas there's my hill now go to
bunny slope we're branching out yeah
good goal
look we understand these olympics are
about being good
they're about competing against the best
in the world and money sometimes is a
problem but if you're one of the best
athletes out there typically you do
pretty well she was one of the best in
the united states so she was going from
having millions of dollars in
sponsorship to having more millions of
dollars in sponsorships right this is
somebody working at home depot featured
in the ad barely making it through life
right it's like fast and the furious
chinese market exactly so look a post a
post on red bull's website that said you
renounced her citizenship was actually
taken down after they were contacted by
the wall street journal and obviously
the idea in china that some u.s skier
that's fantastic actually renounced
their citizenship right and is leaving
to go there is fantastic for them
they're laughing at us saying like this
is a huge win for china this woman
shouldn't be allowed back in the country
well so that's the thing she should
never be allowed back in this country
she should she is we need to see the
passport she has made her tiny wooden
bed she should be she should she should
lie in it with the foot bindings that
come along with it they say juicy right
so she grew up in california with access
to the best training facilities the best
coaches she skied in lake tahoe she had
an american father a chinese mother but
she was born here
again no dual citizenship at all that's
like kim jong-il went to a school in the
states with like was it benjamin
netanyahu yeah i don't understand that's
like just capture him don't let him go
back or no he's still in switzerland i
think
but it's surprising how many foreign
evil dictators come to the united states
like i did uh i did my pre-law at yale
and then killed two million people
we had to figure out how to
i did my residency in uh concentration
camp yeah so
keep in mind though that china's one
child policy didn't end until 2015. we
just mentioned it literally so do you
think she would have had the same access
to the coaches and the ability to ski
and to go out and do that and be trained
and all of these things or do you think
she would have even survived no to be a
skier or an athlete it's not a three
child limit too it's a three child limit
now oh okay so she if she was number
four that's the unlucky number four so i
can have two boy and maybe one girl
defending how i feel at hospital right
yeah oh i prefer three boy
you're having a quintup ritz which means
you get to choose
so here's here's a quote i want to read
to you from her i'm just not going to
answer dave at all
in a 2022 interview uh with a south
china morning post gu said nobody can
deny i'm american when i go to china
nobody can deny i'm chinese that's wrong
hold on time out time out
which one do you want yeah because you
benefited from the system set up here
and now you're going over there for a
money play yeah
go ahead you never get an american
passport again that's totally fine it's
very similar to by the way china they
benefit from the american capitalist
system with trade and then they say that
oh you know the decadence of the west
the truth is if we actually cut cut cut
back on our technology trading right
they talk it would harm china far more
than the united states yeah absolutely
and if we don't want to go to war hey
you know what start off with not just
diplomacy writing a letter but
you know tighten the vice a little bit
right exactly oh you're killing girls uh
you're not allowing people to be free oh
you're actually committing genocide
against the weakers guess what we're not
going to blow you up though we'd kind of
be justified we're just not going to
allow you to have access to our modern
technology that was developed under the
of course free enterprise system that
you hate so much that's the issue and
this is just a person who's embodying
it's basically just flip-flopping right
and i know the olympics are coming up
and i know people tend to watch them i
mean it's it's still pretty popular even
though i don't think fans are allowed
this year but she's basically saying
that i look american and i look chinese
or i sound these ways well hold on
you've totally missed out on what being
american is it's an idea yeah this isn't
about looking a certain way or sounding
a certain way it's about espousing
certain principles and you've gone to
the country that espouses the exact
opposite of freedom yeah and you've done
it for money using freedom to piggyback
off of right but here's another thing so
look if you're if you're really mad
right now if you're a little bit pissed
off that this person did that that's
fantastic
we're not about boycotts or anything
like that boycotts are fantastic in this
case we want you to support an american
skier 17 year old hannah fall heber
goo's biggest american competition in
the halfpipe who has a pretty good shot
of winning as well so if you're going to
watch the olympics when this girl comes
on eileen gu
make sure you give her no cheer no
applause whatsoever well support this
american this year this uh american here
um hannah probably not getting the same
victory listen well what i agree yeah
yeah i mean more of an old navy listen
she's she's like an rei girl come on
talbot
talbots at best
by the way you said you said you don't
think we should compete i disagree i
think that only hurts the athletes in
these cases
um because you've got a very limited
window to be able to compete i know
sometimes it's more about you know
something else going on in the world in
the country doing stupid stuff i get it
but it only hurts them but we did we
were very stern we're not sending our
delegation oh yes that's what i was you
sit there and you did the media says
this with a straight face like a
diplomatic boycott what does that mean
you show up with a few signs yeah
exactly or no that you don't show up at
all like no they had people with signs
there you're doing nothing yeah exactly
it's like oh thank god joe biden's not
gonna come we don't have to like act
like he's actually coherent yeah this is
the issue here look do you want us think
that the united states is on uh
is on more stable footing with china you
can comment below with former vice
president joe biden this is what's all
think about it the president who started
no new major wars donald trump
intimidated all the right people
yeah yep china started playing ball now
i was like yeah well yeah yeah yeah no
wait now we take your skier well i look
she all now your skill belongs to me i
wouldn't be brutal about this but i
would absolutely be like hey totally
fine you want to immigrate to china you
want to naturalize as a citizen all
right hand over that passport let's just
make sure if you want to come back by
the way you're going to have to apply to
be able to come back just like everybody
else that does that right to be able to
come back on a temporary basis or if you
want to work here and make money in the
united states you need to get a workers
permit we got to do all this stuff
because you've just renounced u.s
citizenship right and also we would put
her immediately on the do not accept
list ah yes yeah like send it back for
covid yeah i just no i think if you if
you go and play for the people don't
this is again it goes back to the idea
of of war yeah not just war we're not at
a war with china but you know what when
sometimes people say oh man they want to
have you uh they want to have you all
mixed up in your head with teams no
teams do
matter
and you don't get to be team usa and
team china you don't get to do it you
don't get to be a member of a team that
requires you betraying and renouncing
your other team you wanna you wanna ski
for china great go live in china you
can't come back
and it's not the same as someone having
dual citizenship between the united
states and someone who was born in i
don't know honduras finland switzerland
canada i don't even know if i still
technically i meant technically i
probably still have a canadian
citizenship i have no idea if i ever
knew it because i was born in the states
but ray's there my mom's canadian but
there's a big difference between huge
that and a government that demands you
renounce your american citizenship yeah
and breaking the rules so that you can
do it so we'll we'll see if any more
comes out we'll uh we'll let you know
but i will have that uh victoria's
secret catalog okay open for a fall
before we have b.j dichter real name on
the ground uh from the uh the convoy
there in canada he's going to be uh
calling in on the ground in a few
minutes here uh in canada to update us
um there is a tie-in here a little bit
so uh let's talk about this first
facebook because
and this all goes back to you know you
see spotify what happened and
uh with joe rogan and a lot of people
have been talking it's become sort of a
cultural movement look
the left right now is on a censorship
purge let me be clear about this spotify
is just the beginning with a you know
they don't want a label and by the way
you know that if joe rogan
never uttered the words covid19 or
coronavirus or pandemic they still would
have gone after him it's about
eliminating competition because all
cable news programs combined
don't have the listenership of joe rogan
and it's just him and one guy basically
in uh you know in a den i think in his
house i don't know i used to have a
studio there in los angeles but the
point is it's far lower budget reaches
far more people and they can't have that
they need to keep their gatekeepers in
place that's what they require and so
the left right now they have the same
problem you see with trudeau and the
convoy but
we also addressed uh jen saki today and
joe biden complimenting spotify saying
that they're not doing enough we also
have other government officials and this
ties into facebook that's trending right
now but for all the wrong reasons other
government officials uh demanding that
facebook get more aggressive with its
censoring so i'm sorry um by the way
this uh this next person we have you
know she's obviously held like elected
office also has a victoria secret
catalog coming out here's aoc talking
about facebook
there are some things that
the united states provide that are
welcome
there's also things that we want the
united states to stop exporting and one
of those things is disinformation
and disinformation through
u.s founded companies like facebook that
have absolutely slowed and frankly
sabotaged the global effort to fight
against the coronavirus man she hit all
the liberal words there just like if you
were playing a word game how much what's
the over under on her saying global on
her saying misinformation think about
this she's saying we need a global
government cabal if you will to
determine what is permissible and what
is impermissible now i have a problem
with facebook and i'll get to that in a
second because we've actually been
throttled on facebook we actually baked
code into our page that we could not
become a show page we've been censored
non-stop on facebook and when people say
it's not censorship unless it's
government well
really is it not considered government
any anymore when they say oh yeah we are
removing uh information on facebook that
is misinformation who's telling you it's
misinformation the government the
government's telling us we do what the
government asks they are just
they are just an arm they're a bully
pulpit for the government so let me give
you a couple of other examples of people
tweeting this out this is trending right
now on twitter i don't know if it's
trending on facebook haven't checked
facebook in a long time delete facebook
is trending
writer for the atlantic molly zhang fast
tweeted facebook doesn't need to be the
toxic echo chamber it's become a
facebook contact manager's cared they
would cut down on anti-vaccine content
and various other lies like joe rogan
interviewing the creator of the mrna
vaccine doctors you know real honest to
god doctors not phds in philosophy right
so they don't count you know if you're
on a plane if you're on a plane and
someone was choking you say do we have a
doctor and someone would pop up you know
like a peter mccully like not you does
anyone have a doctor in humanities
wearing beats by dre yes doctor uh
author and phd from harvard and they're
like no you don't right
and he's like no i do though what were
you published
author and lgbtq activist amy siskind
tweeted facebook we are the most
despised brand for being a platform that
spreads disinformation spotify hold my
beer uh of course you all love brianna
woo progressive pack director she's
around said facebook is really on the
path it deserves it nothing to reign in
conservative hate speech and
disinformation and now its user base has
stopped growing no one wants to hang out
with their crazy uncle the meta play is
a desperate and sad attempt to regain
coolness now see you saw me do it change
my mind i think six or seven years ago
that hate speech is not real people say
well people can speak hatefully yep yep
but guess what that was a trojan horse
that allowed it in now we have another
one misinformation what does that mean
well it's uh you know what was
considered a lie yesterday but is
accurate today so what is misinformation
well like six months ago if you said
that if you were vaccinated you know um
you could still catch it or spread it
that was misinformation then and it's
it's not now uh what about the surgeon
general saying don't wear masks they
don't help well no that wasn't
misinformation but then it was
misinformation and it's not so they can
determine what it is hate speech what is
hate speech well they can determine
whatever hate speech is and i'll get to
this in a second it's absolutely
terrifying now facebook has seen a 20
what is it 25 5
nose dive in their stock 200 million
lost in market value that's 18 uh the
first uh first drop in users in their
18-year history oh wow now here's the
thing
they're bitching about misinformation
and what they're saying is let one side
is saying hey we have a problem with
facebook right us here people on the
right side we have a problem with
facebook because they're eliminating
voices they're eliminating voices from
the pool and keep in mind these people
are pitching about an echo chamber yeah
exactly about an echo chamber let's
remove joe rogan let's remove stephen
crowd let's remove james o'keefe let's
remove doctors what has facebook done
well right now uh they just removed
actually the convoy to dc group
uh and this had 130 000 members holy cow
uh and this is something of course that
was modeling the uh canadian obviously
yeah freedom convoy and we'll get to b.j
in a second but when we say okay we have
a problem with facebook well let me tell
you exactly how i have a problem with
facebook and the left just says they
need to do more
what does this is why
this is terrifying these are elected
officials
right saying facebook isn't doing enough
you need to remove more misinformation
well what is facebook done facebook is
throttled conservatives facebook removed
the page of a sitting republican
president facebook removed the pages of
doctors by the way early on in this
pandemic remember when they said a lot
of these measures aren't really working
which now has been confirmed by john
hopkins by the cdc by the who when they
were talking about full lockdown
measures not even saying anything about
mass because we could get removed from
youtube because you know gensake made a
call to wojitsky so
this is what they've done
and by the way they're already labeling
anything that is critical of lord fouch
anything that is critical of let's say
mrna vaccines anything that is critical
of the idea that we should have mass
watkins it's already being labeled
misinformation if you're watching this
on youtube you probably have a warning
label there if you're watching a clip on
facebook if we're still allowed to
upload there we're occasionally allowed
you're definitely seeing warning labels
so we have warning labels we have
conservative voices entirely banned we
have built-in throttling of pages james
o'keefe's investigative journalism gets
removed even though it is fully in line
with single party consent laws they
don't abide by the laws of the states
they abide by the requests of the
federal government and you have people
like aoc and gensake and joe biden
saying they're not doing enough so what
do you think that they want they [ __ ]
about an echo chamber but what is it
they want they are on a censorship purge
they think they smell blood in the water
with joe rogan and they want to remove
voices that they don't agree with i am
so past the silly libertarian argument
that go create your own facebook this is
not this is not a free open economy when
the government can pressure them into
doing their bidding and facebook and
youtube and twitter they've bragged
about having meetings with government
officials and being acquiescent this is
not an example of a private business
saying sure you know what we'll bake
your cake we're just not going to uh
take part in a gay wedding that is not
the same thing
as one of the biggest companies that has
ever existed who receive receive
countless tax benefits and protections
under safe harbor laws saying we're
going to do exactly what the government
tells us and now the government's saying
you're not doing enough there are still
people running against us who are on
there you got to get rid of them think
trump was a good start
james o'keefe was a good but get rid of
everybody else
right and it's not just limited to
health right saying oh this is what's
best for people because you're actually
affecting people's health you're causing
them to die
there's so many stories the hunter biden
laptop the russia stuff that was going
on that they did let go through right
peeing prostitutes and everything else
going on and then they kicked something
out that directly affected an election
hey you know what we're talking about
people's health how about you stop
removing posts critical of fat pride how
about that there we go how about how
about you start removing posts of you
know doctors and medical experts and
people from mayo clinic and johns
hopkins how about your how about you how
about you stop removing if you're so
concerned about health how about ron
desantis talking to three of doctors
from places that are the most revered in
the world i believe it was oxford
stanford and harvard
having a conversation with his citizens
at the time sitting governor of one of
the biggest states in the united states
and before we go to canada uh the the
man bj dictor in canada look when
everyone talked about donald trump being
an authoritarian fascist okay sent out
some mean tweets got it do you ever
remember
donald trump let's say ted cruz let's
say run to santas people you don't like
right if you don't like them
can you point me to a single example of
them saying
hey facebook
youtube twitter you need to remove more
content you need to get rid of these
people or did you see them bitching
about social media saying you need to
stop removing content there's a big big
difference look the authoritarian regime
is not the one that says
hey people should have the right to more
guns hey people should keep more of
their paycheck hey people should be
allowed to speak freely on all social
platforms you're going to say that's
authoritarian and that's fascist but not
the government that wants to take away
your right to self-preservation to
self-defense and your right to speak
freely even if you're a qualified doctor
listen this is just the word play that
goes on the word fascist authoritarian
it's never been the guy who says
take all the guns
take all the guns and post anywhere
because that's how i get control is by
allowing you to protect yourself and
speak freely no just because joe biden
looks like he has pipe cleaners on his
head and puts on a nice guy g golly will
rogers act does not mean that this is
not a dangerous authoritarian time in
our country and you know why this is
important people look
i don't want
we just said this yes i don't want
whoopi goldberg to be removed and that
wasn't censorship that's a network they
have the right to do it i think she made
it in i think she made a silly statement
and of course i'll call her out for it
but i don't want to see people removed
for opinions and i certainly don't want
to see it on social media because all
great civil rights revolutions start
with speech you give that power over you
don't get it back and you see what's
happening in canada and this is getting
this is close to a civil information war
when you have what is the equivalent to
the united states president prime
minister of canada it's a silly place
it's inconsequential generally speaking
in comparison okay we love our canadian
brethren but you have the prime minister
of the country speaking out
and saying
that there are certain views which are
impermissible and shouldn't be allowed
to be spoken or
written these are the people who are
ironically called liberals and these are
the people trying to shut down really
the only peaceful mass protests that i
can think of the last half decade there
hasn't even been an injury
in these canadian protests this has been
admitted by the way by their own police
forces said no it could have there could
have been a really bad you know injury
or something but did it happen no they
just put a canadian flag on terry fox
and then cleaned it up oh all right so
peaceably assembling i wouldn't go that
far what would you call it oh scary
so remember trudeau called unvaccinated
canadians uh and now these trucker
convoys we have bj dictor here who's on
the ground to discuss it uh
racists fascists sexist and said that
they hold unacceptable views in case you
forgotten
about
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable uh views uh that
they're expressing done tyrant do not
represent
the views of canadians don't even want
to hear the rest
unacceptable views done tyrant period
that's it you've crossed the line
that's it
no leader
of an allegedly free country gets to
determine what is an unacceptable view
outside of actual violent crime of
course i need to say that done that's it
you're a tyrant he needs to be out
uh he also wrote this uh on tuesday
tweeting uh today in the house members
of parliament unanimously condemned the
anti-semitism islamophobia anti-black
racism homophobia and transphobia that
we've seen on display in ottawa over the
past number of days this written by a
guy who's a blackface connoisseur well
it just so happens that we actually have
one of these sexist transphobic racist
truckers live on the show right now
[Music]
all right how are you doing steven i am
doing well i can't see you yet hold on
one second uh tim the tool man is going
to bring you up for people who are
watching you can find him on the twitter
at bj dictor he's uh one of the
spokespeople for the uh the truckers
right now the freedom convoy he joined
in late january and uh by the way uh
politifact says there's only in the
hundreds to low thousands of protesters
we just heard that from the prime
minister i've heard numbers as high as
50 000. mr dichter thank you for being
here can you clarify that for us
well i would never uh accuse the left of
being terribly good at math
or finances or anything like that so
it's thousands we have no idea it's been
you know two weeks now and we're still
trying to aggregate data see where
certain teams are people are on farmers
fields all over the country
and they're not uh we can't get like a
detailed uh can't we will eventually but
it's it's literally thousands but you
know stephen i just i just want to
comment on what you said before
um you know you have a movement right
now where the two spokespersons are a
metis woman and a jew but black face
is the tolerant one that's the town
world that we live in well no no hold on
a second i have to fact-check you by the
way if you could tilt the camera up a
little bit you have a wonderful clavicle
and beard but i do there you go i want
to see the face
um he's not just black face
he was a black body he did his arms he
did his legs like i don't think i've
ever seen anyone love i wish i loved
anything as much as prime minister
trudeau looked like banana yeah remember
the banana he put in his pants like what
the hell and he sang the banana song
i mean it couldn't be any worse for
crying out loud um now before we move on
what was that when was this
trudeau yeah oh he did it like a million
times we'll show you
same with blackface yeah i have to count
his number of black faces i have to use
an abacus
you count them with bananas yes exactly
and then it's like donkey kong where you
just do that level where you leave and
go right back and you get the banana
hoard that's how many times he did
blackface but let me ask you this hey uh
pj you felt
you were late today because you fell in
a in a ditch i understand and we saw
videos of people putting nails on the
road yesterday
is that what happened did you mad max
you got nails on your tires
you know maybe that's what i'll tell my
insurance company no it's uh you
remember how warm canada is in the
winter yeah it's one of those days where
it's a sheet of ice and just you know
the tail end slipped out and the next
thing i knew i've never had that before
in my life next thing you know i was in
a ditch in a tree so uh we're off to a
rock and start at the convoy today it's
only gonna get better from here right
right well you were gonna call us in
front of parliament where are you right
now it looks like you're at a at a truck
stop or a bingo hole i'm in canada where
else would i be oh good
other than tim hortons right in a place
that has no uber
no rental cars uh i don't have cellular
signal i don't know where i am
but i do have some people from the
convoy going to rescue me oh okay well
that's wonderful those uh you know i
mean racist xenophobic nazis
you should see what the fake news media
is doing to me because i got up on the
stage in front of i don't know 30 40 50
000 people last week
and i gave concrete examples of what i
call the fake news cdc and i explained
that last week they were running a
series of stories that our gofundme was
frozen from the very beginning and i
told my team don't say anything don't
correct them i want to bait them so they
went the entire week reporting oh it was
for nefarious reasons or racist or
whatever phobe whatever
but what was happening is we were just
sharing paperwork back and forth
and it takes you know gofundme is not
the fastest when you set up a campaign
right usually takes
seven to ten days and i know that's
exactly what we're dealing with so once
it was approved it was uh everything
started it was fine we ran out ran a
presser that you know uh all the fake
news that you've been reading has been
fake and gofundme uh has started
relinquishing uh releasing the funds
that was until two days ago
i believe it was uh mainstream media
people they were brigading the accounts
and trying to to mass report as many as
which triggers the algorithm right and
now we're going back and forth with
gofundme again but at least now we got a
team of lawyers who flew in
so it's not going to be advocated just
for gofundme
continue freezing well that'll be fun
it's just going to cost us some money
whatever that'll be fun yeah too because
your lawyers in canada will have to pay
for those silly wigs they'll show up
with their judges people don't realize
here how it works but let me ask let me
ask you this um well first off let me
comment i always tell americans they
don't fully understand when they [ __ ]
about corporate media you just touched
on cbc americans don't know that's the
canadian broadcasting corporation the
alternative is cbc
and that is government-run media so you
have government-run media putting
pressure on a private organization
gofundme to stop the funds for what
a mass uprising a mass peaceful uprising
protesting the government think of that
protest the government government media
says gofundme you better freeze these
funds what is it up to by the way how
much have you guys raised in gofundme
it's many many millions
last i checked it was 10 million 100 000
and that's when they put the hard stop
on it
so we can't uh receive any more fun so i
actually put a post out yesterday saying
uh should we actually start collecting
funds with bitcoin by any chance and
boom people started sending me wallets
saying we've been collecting for you in
bitcoin already and the last wallet i
saw i got to confirm it today but it had
something like 46 000 in bitcoin already
so you know where there's a will there's
a way right yeah but you're gonna have
to deal with a pain in the ass all the
crypto people you should really be doing
ethereum it's like shut up all right
it's just gonna be warring with each
other and there's one percent
i'll mine some more can you tell people
here in the united states because they
see bits and pieces out of context um
okay
what is this about i mean it's obviously
about protesting the vaccine mandate but
what is going on right now in canada you
know i was raised there from three to
eighteen never experienced anything like
this which is going on and i'm proud to
see it what do americans need to know if
they're just tuning in right now and
they go what's going on with canada
truckers something explain to them
okay so the first we're protesting or
the vaccine mandate and the vaccine
passport so what is the vaccine passport
that means anytime you come into canada
you're gonna have to have this app
downloaded into your phone
and it will uh track the status of your
kovid shot so if you need more shots and
you don't get them
then you
you don't pass you have to go back to
the united states as a trucker and you
have to get a pcr test and wait whatever
the period of time is and then come back
but the other thing is this affects you
guys as well because the biden
administration is implementing the same
thing right however we know from our
friends within politics and in
journalism apparently the binding
administration even the biden
administration had zero interest in this
but the trudeau government apparently
lobbied the biden administration and
convinced them to adopt a similar
process we don't know why we don't know
if they're going to be sharing data
across the border with people going into
the u.s and vice versa yes but this is
the basis of social credit i explained
when i was on tucker carlson the first
time i used it i drove up to the the
booth
and i held up my my passport and the guy
says to me no i don't need to see it i
mean you don't need to see it he said
well when your truck drives up and it's
within a certain vicinity of the border
all your details and information comes
up on my computer so and it's correlated
with your passport so i can already see
it you don't have to show it to me great
so when are we going to start
implementing that across every city in
canada and then ultimately the united
states like this is crazy draconian
stuff yeah that's also tough for the
booth operator because he's like i got
to close all my windows of porn new
truck came up um well now let me ask did
you get a question you're about to ask
though joel gerald is here hold on he
has to ask it we have so many questions
here i appreciate you making the time i
mean especially considering that you
just had air bags going off in your
right yeah exactly just proving that
it's hard to drive on ice thank you for
making that point for me for from
yesterday but how how long uh how long
do you guys plan on staying i know right
now that there's been some i know that
the police were saying that they were
going to break stuff up and ask people
to leave or force people to leave or
give tickets or tow like what's the
status of how many people are there
right now as far as trucks and how long
they intend on staying
i don't know 20 22 20 20 sorry 2024
maybe
until things change
the thing is is going around and
building this narrative you know white
supremacists and a confederate flag it's
canada we don't have confidence i know i
would just say i was like you know
unless someone actually zoomed in on the
english flag and distorted it and like
yeah it kind of looks like a confederate
flag i guess they're union jack but yeah
i saw it and immediately knew that it
was a bad actor it's fairly north well
the guy was wearing a black balaclava
and i automatically assumed oh it's
justin trudeau
especially
[Laughter]
the thing is what we have some people on
our command team like we have a central
command and we have ex-military and ex
police police officers there so they
know all the protocols of crowd control
making it safe having emergency vehicle
pathways
and in back and forth with the police
over the past week a week and a half
they
understand that as disorganized because
it just blew up and went parabolic they
understand that we're spending all of
our time keeping everybody's morale up
making it the biggest block party in uh
in
canada's history otherwise known as
hashtag trudeau's truck stop right right
in front of his office and it's a party
atmosphere it's great it's it's so much
fun well i would i wouldn't use the term
block party because there's some members
in quebec like hey don't steal our name
[Music]
you'll understand this and you explain
this to the audience when i first got
there the first day before everything
started the pre-day there were i
couldn't believe this
thousands of people tens of thousands of
people maybe
walking
across the border from quebec
into ottawa with quebec flags and
ontario flags and we saw them all
going to meet up with you know people
truckers from alberta and saskatchewan
and regina and whatever and they were
all just hanging out yeah they couldn't
speak to each other it was funny they're
trying to figure out how do you speak
english how to speak french but they're
hugging each other they're hanging out
and this is what happens when the media
and uh our politicians get out of the
way you know what people actually can
unify it was the most beautiful
experience i've ever seen in all my time
of in canada it's like as though the
gavin newsom californians went to like
mississippi and decided to you know hold
hands and unify together it was amazing
well you know what i have a still a lot
of french canadian family and a lot of
people don't realize that northern
quebec you know once you go out of
montreal they tend to be very
conservative even the old separatists a
lot of it was based on some conservative
ideas they just sort of got it wrong
they thought that they were not being
fairly represented in the taxation but a
lot of them you know they're hunters up
there i mean i have an uncle who hunts
caribou and uh they've they actually
became big trump fans think about that
remo ma say he was like man uh i like
trump uh carl is that man he's uh he's a
man you know and i was like man these
french they really have changed and
here's one thing i want to point out and
i want to get back to um because we have
a big portion of our audience that's
canadian and i'd like you to
tell us how we can mobilize them too but
americans don't fully understand this
you know when they say oh big tech it's
not censorship because it's not
government look for
a place a place where we live the united
states it's really pretty bad and it's
getting scary that they have these
gatekeepers online you know you see
spotify and facebook and youtube
but at least even you just mentioned
tucker carlson there are still options
even in traditional media outlets in a
place like canada where people can
exaggerate that and take a place like
venezuela where your only source of news
when i was there i know now you have
like rebel news things like that but
your only source of news is government
funded the government telling big tech
platforms who to remove is catastrophic
and there can be
no uh protest there can no longer be any
civil disobedience i don't think
americans realize it can all go away if
the internet becomes um this sort of
this sort of authoritarian wasteland
that we see saki and joe biden want
well i think what's happening here is in
terms of the fake news media so cbc
toronto star when we had our first press
conference i went on to twitter and
jordan peterson put up that that graphic
that the toronto star published and you
know the cbc was publishing fake news
articles about us all week so i went on
the twitter and i said all right first
press conference cbc and the toronto
star are banned from our first
conference and we've been bringing in
all these you know independent creators
social media people uh who are you know
young uh independent journalists a
couple people one from the national post
and you know true north and epoch times
but the rest of them were all
independent creators
and i said to them we sat down and i
said look
we're not going to have the cbc come in
with a giant you know
phallic camera that's 30 feet tall and
50 people and take up all the the floor
space this is for you guys we'll be here
as long as you want two hours three
hours i don't care
you ask us anything let's have a
dialogue and a conversation and andrew
lawton from uh true north center who's a
fantastic journalist i know i met him
about six years ago yeah
oh you froze him uh oh he is canada yeah
i was gonna say he's literally frozen as
well
his uh his digital assets as well as his
asset well they're all frozen his
potatoes let's see if we need to call
him uh let's see if we need to hang up
and call him back because i want to tell
people also too who are watching here uh
in the united states and ask him about
this
again uh this is how important it is to
have an open and free internet as far as
and i don't just mean this as far as net
neutrality and bandwidth i'm talking
about people being able to have a
dialogue because that's how truth can
get out that's why you don't want to
keep let's say maduro
on twitter and get rid of a donald trump
get rid of a convoy because what you end
up with isn't there are a few videos
going around with uh with this right now
and i want to show a clip remember the
australia-style covid camps yeah uh
they're seeing these beings set up in
places like british columbia
and canada here's someone who actually
filmed it and of course you don't see it
on the uh canadian funded government
broadcast here
all right so i've gone on a little trip
and i'm in the middle almost
geographically the middle of british
columbia
um just west of vanderhoof and
i'm uh
i came across this i'm like what the
hell there's it's like a jail in the
middle of nowhere so if you don't
believe it wake the [ __ ] up
so who are these for who are all these
camps for and why is there electric
fences
electric fence and barbed wire it's a
freaking prison
hmm that is absolutely terrifying i
think we lost bj uh but you know what
the guy already gave us enough time and
we're running late as it is uh people
you can follow him at bj dictor we'll
have the information for the if it's the
gofundme or right bitcoin whatever it is
we're going to make sure that we have it
available link in the description where
you guys can go and support them almost
10 of our audience is canadian yeah so
uh we'll also be talking about this more
this is this is something that hopefully
ends up being mirrored in the united
states and isn't it insane when you just
think of how the media here and trudeau
he said for example i'll meet with
people who i agree with black lives
matter was an excellent example of this
that's not how that's not how democracy
works that's not how constitutional
republic works the whole point is to
have conversations with people
you disagree and by the way especially
if they're peaceful so you were kneeling
for people who were violent
and by people i mean some but certainly
more than zero which is what you're
seeing from this convoy zero acts of
violence whatsoever
but you don't you don't meet with these
folks and all these folks are asking is
that you don't force upon them
a digital coding software that you don't
spy on them the other
activists are demanding that you uh you
know
i mean depending which country you're in
destroy the nuclear family reparations
reallocate resources from white
businesses to black businesses you know
simple stuff racist stuff these people
are saying just don't stick a needle in
us and make us have to have a digital
passport eh and if you have to just
don't make the numbers six and then six
and another six
that's a fair that's an easy ask i mean
go with sevens that that's about the
yeah all right well look uh i guess
we'll tease it out this has been uh bj
dictor and we'll have him on again next
week yeah there we go
[Music]
god that's terrifying nice fella and
people don't realize i've never seen
anything like that in canada when i was
raised there by the way i love their
response to it though and i love that it
was truck drivers who were like all
right that's enough and like you said it
should be mirrored in the united states
i think it is being mirrored right now
there are plans i think in the works to
do something like this in the u.s
and thank god like you somebody has to
stand up well then they get removed from
facebook though no i know that's the
promise so you can't mobilize but think
about this it's the government saying
hey you need to do more aoc right we
just talked about i feel like i know i'm
being repetitive but i hope i drill this
in your skull do you see the magnitude
of elected representatives here in the
united states
telling these platforms what to allow
and what to ben is the is the freedom
convoy to dc with 130 what's the
misinformation there there hasn't even
been a reason given at the time of this
broadcast i'm sure they'll trump up some
charges yeah the government says hey
they're not allowed and people are
saying we're going to go out and protest
the government facebook says no you're
not
now i get it they can allow but one side
can plan riots and burning down
walgreens on all digital platforms the
other one has to hand out physical
flyers in their neighborhood like lost
in founds to gather peacefully and make
their voices heard that's no longer
freedom yeah and politicians aren't
bailing these truckers out like they
were with blm or having kamala harris
say yeah they should be bailed out and
back on the streets right we're
contributing to that fund right you're
helping facilitate what they're doing
that your country has laws does not make
it free it's are these laws applied
equally yeah and right now they're
having these these bullies these thugs
in the big tech realm
uh enforcing their laws selectively and
that's a problem you have to say
something there dave
i don't remember okay
uh yeah
that's your point
do you think windsor is a bit different
though than that part of uh canada well
he's in ottawa i mean canada is just
it's here's the problem with canada yeah
this is why i'm surprised by it you do
have a country whose history is uh
bowing to the royalty that's going to
have a very different culture than the
united states who fought off the royalty
and so just like you know people talk
about gun crime in japan they say well
in japan they ban guns there's no gun
crime you're talking about people who
were under the thumb of imperialism and
that's their culture right you can't
compare the japanese culture to the
united states culture and by the way it
comes with serious ramifications that
americans would not want to have to live
with including rampant racism but that
being said you do have canadians who are
very polite and kind of go along they're
not nearly as disruptive this is a
really big uncomfortable step for people
in canada in the united states we're
used to protests like this in canada
they usually never even get started
they definitely get started when they
win the uh you know the championships in
hockey so well they right whether they
win or lose well now yeah but uh yeah
but they're happy riots yeah
i don't understand a happy riot we would
let's burn the car uh it's when riots
are mostly peaceful yes yeah where have
you been where's the best yeah well
that's actually what happened in
montreal they want the the canadians
lost the stanley cup and if they won the
stanley cup there was a riot i remember
laughing my ass off watching it where a
guy on camera this is me as a child i
just remember laughing like they were
rioting the guy was on top of a cop car
he busts a levi's store window grabs a
stack of jeans and the cbc was it and he
goes
and he's drunk and then another guy who
is larger than him walks on the hood of
the cop car and takes the stack from him
and walks away and that goes like hey
he's looking for a police officer i'm
going that's that's the law
that's how it works yeah you just stole
i need to report my stolen stolen goods
yes yes exactly they've been re-stolen
officer yes well it's just like you know
when black lives matter they say yeah
and then you shouldn't have guns well
what do we do we call the racist cops
all right thank you i appreciate that
circular non-logic hey before uh we uh
well actually you know what let me try
and hit this story here okay uh you know
the other day
neil young he was being an [ __ ] well
but it turns out he has a long history
of that and actually thanks to dave and
some people in the research team here we
found some of his horrible tweets that
would yeah you know warrant getting
anybody else canceled not him uh and no
this is no not neil young no of course
because joe rogan you know uh
interviewing doctors is more problematic
than this direct quote from neil young
in an interview with melody maker in
1985 he backed reagan's gun control
policies and he said this of aids you go
to a supermarket and you see a
i don't even know if i can say this word
[ __ ] and then get behind
the [ __ ] cash register you don't want
him to handle your potatoes and there
are more by the way i'll reference the
video about letters quoting him i'm
quoting him directly
come on i'm quoting the great neil young
but um i don't know if this shouldn't
have come as a surprise yeah because uh
if you've actually heard the original
lyrics to after the gold rush we did
some we did some digging and we found
this old
nightclub
recording neil young hey guys uh it's me
neil young and uh i want to thank you
for your support
i got a song here i'm going to sing
about something i said in 1985.
i'm here to fight spotify as you know i
just want you to know that some things
are not about money
some things are about the truth
eh and it's important to fight
misinformation
all right
here we go
i get scared when i go to buy
potatoes and the cash is a queen
no no no no no no no there's no way
we're going to be able to play this on
youtube and i don't want to take the
heat for i can take the heat for things
that i say yeah yeah i don't want to get
struck on youtube for stuff that neil
young said no neil young literally said
and you know what you know here's the
thing
i support his i i
support his right to say it right but i
don't like what it's a little too far
it's a bit too much neil young is a it's
a little too much yeah anyway rob robert
bird is watching going like oh man wow
like come on dude it's just potato pull
it back a little bit okay yeah uh maybe
make spike leo make a film about it but
you know what let's we have the full
recording yeah uh thank you bj dictor by
the way if you're watching on youtube
smash that like button yeah and comment
below the best thing you can do for the
algorithm is comment but hitting the
like helps as well
and
let me know i know he's trying to hit
both things let me know if you want to
see us continue the mug clubhouse
because uh we stopped because it was way
too high budget and uh unless enough of
you uh vote below
then we're just going to stop it let's
finish the neil young but not not here
youtube
this is for your own good piss off
you